comment la 5g va-t-elle changer nous
crie ça c'est la grosse question la 5g
peut bouleverser notre vie dans
différentes asasp et donc du point de
vue médical seulement quand on parle que
la 5g
c'est une technologie qui va réduire
énormément le temps de latence ce qu'on
appelle techniquement la latence d'un
bout du réseau à notre réseau on peut
imaginer comme nous pourrons faire des
opérations chirurgicales très très très
très précise au bout de la planète avec
une précision énorme et d'autres choses
du point de vue industriel ou bien vu
agriculture dans la 5g on parle de
verticaux qu'est ce que ça veut dire les
verticaux ce sont les en applicatifs
dans laquelle la 5g va se déployer
donc on parle de l'agriculture du futur
avec connecté on parle aussi du
transport maritime connectique on parle
de la voiture connectée
ok on parle aussi des réseaux
intelligents donc la première phase de
la cgil on peut dire que nous sommes
dans une phase de déploiement entre
l'interaction entre humains machine ce
qu'on appelle le déploiement de
technologies et la communication humaine
machine la deuxième phase ça serait de
machine to machine donc de machine à
machine et là on frappera à la porte de
l'industrie 4.0 et avec toutes les
conséquences économiques qui peuvent
venir un derrière et la troisième phase
avec une 5 g plus mûr et qui serait apte
à une autre évolution
ça serait une communication entre
intelligente des agents intelligents
vers d'autres agents intelligents
qu'est ce que c'est un agent intelligent
et ben ce sont des machines qui ont des
capacités aussi de
de faire une exploration de
l'environnement de d'apprendre donc la
notion d'apprentissage aujourd'hui quand
on parle de l'intelligence artificielle
c'est une des parties de l'intelligence
artificielle
c'est le learning c'est-à-dire
l'apprentissage des événements et aussi
on aura la décision de mike keane servir
la prise de décision aujourd'hui on
connaît pas les commentaires de design
de intelligente azur intelligente et
réseaux et ces choses cccd techniques à
développer dans le futur et il y a
et à déployer pour va là pour j'allais
dire il faut que ces des applications
qui pourraient faciliter énormément la
vie quotidienne des gens
[Musique]